it's friday and that means it's time for
friday follies
[Laughter]
all right for that we turn to fox news
contributor the great the awesome the
smart the sexy raymond arroyo all right
how's that in tour right now i think
you're over selling me there sean but
okay
not much not much me a little bit all
right biden went to the west bank in
saudi arabia today and it didn't go so
well
sean at times biden was so
unintelligible i wasn't sure if he was
speaking in the middle east or in middle
earth
an elvish translation
might have
made more sense
in the united states has suffered loss
as well including the killing of shireen
abu
okay uh alkali
and
i had a terrible headache
excuse me a terrible headache
and uh
i'm sorry
i swallowed wrong
i had a terrible headache
this is years
ago and i did a very stupid thing
when i came to office i
reserved the policy i reversed the
policies of my predecessor to respond to
the pandemic including donating more
than one million doses of covet 19
to the west bank in gaza
i'm sure the palestinians were overjoyed
sean to learn that he sent over a
million doses of covet
to their people just what they needed
the good news is the president has
committed a hundred million dollars to
six palestinian hospitals let's hope
they have memory care units and an acid
reflux clinic that cough looks a little
rough for him
it does raymond i wonder if jill biden
or the easter easter bunny didn't tell
joe that coveted was over
no well i think the easter bunny got
lost along the way as well so what are
you gonna do
but i may have all right people have
worked for him for 30 years sean they
claim there's been no change in joe
biden what are they seeing are they do
they have tvs
oh we don't they don't think we have
youtube i know exactly but ray
performances like this on the world
stage are why democrats are looking for
someone that a little bit younger to
lead their party
yeah well you saw that new york times
poll where 94 percent of democrats under
the age of 30 want a candidate other
than biden to run in 2024. so sean if
you're joy read and you want to discuss
the discontent with a nearly 80 year old
president running who would you invite
on why an 81 year old retired democrat
senator barbara boxer
it doesn't matter how old you are you
could be dangerous at 80 and you could
be dangerous at 40. it has nothing to do
with age we could all be they could all
be in their 30s or their 40s they still
couldn't do it and i think i think the
the panelists we have on here is so
right it's about the issues
she couldn't remember the name of her
co-panelist while making the argument
that it doesn't matter their old danger
is sean
well well raymond i look at that point i
go you know what i actually agree with
her because i look at aoc what mid-30s
and bernie sanders 80. they're both
really dangerous it's not their age it's
their ideas that are killing america
well and more than the issues it's
really about how that individual ages
and the truth is joe biden is aging far
more rapidly than other men his age even
ronald reagan in the past and donald
trump
or and donald trump for sure all right
ray tell us about the democrat senate
candidate john fetterman's celebrity
troll of his opponent dr oz
yeah fetterman had a stroke a few weeks
back and uh he's not been on the
campaign trail so he's turning to cameo
for help now that's that service where
you pay celebrities to send anniversary
of birthday greetings to friends so
fetterman paid snooki of jersey shore to
drag dr oz for having lived in new
jersey
hey maymet this is nicole snooki
um and i'm from jersey shore i heard
that you moved from new jersey to
pennsylvania to look for a new job don't
worry because you'll be back home in
jersey soon this is only temporary so
good luck you got this and jersey loves
you
now sean snooki was probably not in on
the joke nor do i think she was
thought she was recording a political ad
since the fetterman campaign posted that
on social media but you know people pay
for the celebrity cameo endorsements all
the time sean
i'm judge jeanine pirro and
raymond arroyo is my favorite part of
friday follies and all of prime time
who the hell is raymond arrow
i knew i should have paid full price for
the judge jeannine cameo next time judge
by the way it's been reported that
fetterman's campaign paid snooki a grand
total of 390 bucks for that cameo sean
that's embarrassing and you know dr oz
actually went to school at the
university of pennsylvania had two
children in pennsylvania and he's
registered to vote there so it's a low
cheap blow no matter what
hold on raymond raymond i i i did
reality tv back in the day i'm not
getting paid to do political ads and
snooki's getting paid almost 400 bucks
i'm missing out here
you are i'm gonna i'm gonna tap into
your
cameo and you can help endorse me next
time we'll do it next week
all right
next week i got you paid judge janine
that's totally wrong raymond raymond
great to see you have a good weekend
friday follies
youtube hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else